[MUSIC - GRACE KELLY]
[CHEERING]
SPEAKER 1: Do we have
room for one more?
Grace Kelly, ladies
and gentlemen.
GRACE KELLY: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER 1: And your
colleagues and friends.
Putting our music
room to very good use.
I think there's a--
oh, You have it.
GRACE KELLY: Yeah, I got one.
SPEAKER 1: It's my
honor and pleasure
to introduce you to
Grace a little bit more,
get to know her.
If you haven't heard
of Grace Kelly,
then you haven't
traveled on the T today.
"Improper Bostonian"
just came out.
GRACE KELLY: Yeah, today.
SPEAKER 1: Just today.
You are incredibly,
incredibly busy.
And you do a lot of
diversified things.
GRACE KELLY: Yeah.
SPEAKER 1: You're originally
from Boston, moved to LA, now
in New York.
GRACE KELLY: Yes.
SPEAKER 1: But Boston this week.
Why?
GRACE KELLY: So
yesterday-- is this on?
This cool?
You can hear?
So yesterday-- I'm part of this
documentary about a mentor--
now it's on.
I'm part of a documentary about
a mentor of mine in music.
He passed away, but he's
the late, great saxophonist
Frank Morgan.
And he was a protégé of the
bebop saxophonist and the king,
Mr. Charlie Parker.
Frank was asked to join
Duke Ellington's orchestra
when he was 18.
But he couldn't because his
parents said he was too young.
And he should be one of
those jazz saxophonists
that everyone knows,
but he spent 30 years
in and out of San
Quentin due to drugs.
So this is a documentary
about his life.
And I got to know him in the
last two years of his life.
And we were very close.
We played a lot.
So that premiered
in Boston at the--
in Brookline at the Brookline
Coolidge Corner Theatre.
And it was exciting.
So that's why I'm here.
Because it's played
at the LA Film Fest.
It's played all over.
But that was its first
screening in the area.
SPEAKER 1: But you'll
also be back in Boston
at the end of the month.
GRACE KELLY: I will.
So May 22, Sunday May
22, you can put it down
in your Google Calendars.
I will be at the Berklee
Performance Center
with a fantastic band of mine.
And we're going to be
celebrating my new CD.
And it's going to be a
multimedia, visual thing
and really cool.
So I hope you guys can come.
It's going to be lots of fun.
SPEAKER 1: Incredible.
So a new CD.
GRACE KELLY: Yeah.
SPEAKER 1: Is this
with a regular band?
GRACE KELLY: So
this CD has probably
20-plus musicians on it--
including special guest
Jon Batiste sings and
plays harmoni-board on it.
Michael League, who's the
founder of the band Snarky
Puppy and plays
bass in that band,
Shayna Steele, Mocean Worker.
But there's a lot of cats,
including band members of mine
and then just other
incredible musicians
that added their talents to it.
SPEAKER 1: And is
this all originals,
or is there a mix of
originals and standards?
GRACE KELLY: It's a mix of it.
There's a good
amount of originals.
And then there's some of
my favorite standards.
And it's kind of a
thematic CD in the way
that from the first
track to the last track,
it goes from
darkness into light.
I called it an emotional
musical journey.
And every song kind of
uncovers more of that.
So that's how I picked
the songs that I wanted.
SPEAKER 1: So then will
you be touring elsewhere
to support the album?
GRACE KELLY: Yeah.
So I've been doing--
we're going to be doing some
stuff in the West Coast coming
up.
And we have some gigs.
I've been doing this gig
with Jon Batiste playing
on "The Late Show
with Stephen Colbert."
So that's like an everyday
thing Monday through Friday.
So it's been a little bit
tricky to figure out how
to kind of get it all together.
But they've been super
flexible in letting
me go off and perform.
Like today, they were
like, OK, go do your thing.
And then I drive back
to New York tonight,
and then I'm on
the show tomorrow.
SPEAKER 1: Wow.
GRACE KELLY: So yeah, it's--
that came up so last
minute for me in December
that it's just been a juggling
act now of being like, OK,
how can we fit in all
of these great things?
SPEAKER 1: Gosh, I can imagine.
So then-- but that's not the
only way we'll see you on TV,
right?
GRACE KELLY: Right.
So I was asked in May--
I think the premier
is May 31, right?
On NBC, there's
a new show called
"Maya & Marty in Manhattan."
And it's Martin Short
and Maya Rudolph.
It's kind of an updated
Carol Burnett variety show.
And I was asked to be
in the band for that.
So I'm hopping over
to Rockefeller Center
to record that.
SPEAKER 1: Sweet.
GRACE KELLY: And that's going
to be six episodes, right
after "America's
Got Talent" on NBC.
So you can tune in.
The first episode
will be May 31.
And it's supposed to be a lot
of musical guests and comedians,
so I'm guessing it's
going to be really fun.
SPEAKER 1: But then you're
also on an Amazon show, right?
GRACE KELLY: Yes, I am.
Yeah, it's been a TV
year, which is great.
SPEAKER 1: I'm exhausted
just [INAUDIBLE]..
GRACE KELLY: So some of you
might know the great "New York
Times" best-selling
author Michael Connelly.
And he writes these
detective novels.
One of them is
about Harry Bosch.
I mean he's written
20-something books about him.
And it got turned into a TV show
that Amazon Prime picked up.
So season one was
super successful.
People loved it.
It's so well-done.
And then in season two,
it features my band
and me playing in front of the
main character Harry Bosch.
And I'm playing a
song that I wrote
for him called "Blues
for Harry Bosch," which
is the first track on the CD.
And so that came out March
11, the whole season.
And it's very binge
watching worthy.
And they just got the green
light for season three too.
But it came about--
Michael Connelly, the
author, wrote an email to me.
And he said, hey, I wrote a
part for you in our TV show.
Any chance that you
would want to come do it?
I was like, hmm, let me check.
Yeah, I'm free.
I'm very free.
SPEAKER 1: You have to
clear it with Colbert.
But otherwise, you're free.
So it's interesting.
So you work with
Stephen Colbert.
GRACE KELLY: Yeah.
SPEAKER 1: And you're doing this
show with Martin Short and Maya
Rudolph.
GRACE KELLY: Yeah.
SPEAKER 1: All master
improvisers in comedy.
GRACE KELLY: Yeah, totally.
SPEAKER 1: You yourself a
master improviser in music.
GRACE KELLY: Thanks.
SPEAKER 1: Now what
is that relationship?
Do you get to collaborate
improvisationally
with these folks?
What is that relationship like?
GRACE KELLY: Well, it's
just super fun for me
because I love the
spontaneity of jazz.
And like the fact that
we all just got together
this afternoon and playing
music that we didn't even
rehearse before today, that's
kind of how Stephen operates.
It's really fun.
Like certain
moments in the show,
you might not see it because
it's during commercial breaks.
But for the live audience,
he'll come over to the band.
And he'll start singing
and dancing with us
or just go over to the
piano and start playing.
And so it's just the mentality
behind these great comedians
with the musicians.
We're all from the same
language, which I love.
So it just makes everything
feel much more fluid.
SPEAKER 1: And then
according to your bio,
you say that not only do you
use improvisational techniques
or mindset in your music, but
also in the rest of your life.
GRACE KELLY: Totally.
SPEAKER 1: Can you
give an example
of some non-musical-related
incident or anything where
improvisation helped you?
GRACE KELLY: Yeah, yeah.
I mean I think it's
really important--
since I've been studying jazz
and studying improvisation,
it just kind of
creeps into my life.
And sometimes I'm way more
laid back about situations
than I probably should be.
But it's just how
I've been trained.
But there was this
one time years
ago that I was supposed to go to
the Apollo Theater in New York
City to go see a show that
featured all the jazz greats.
Like Dave Brubeck was
there, Wynton Marsalis.
The woman putting on the concert
was like, yeah, you can get in.
I'll get you backstage.
So I was super excited.
And then last minute,
she said, actually,
all the tickets are sold out.
And we can't get you in.
And so maybe the
non-improvising Grace
would be like, oh shoot,
and just super bummed out,
and go to my hotel, and
eat Twizzlers and be sad.
But I was with one of
my mentors that night.
And he said, well, why don't
we go to Roth's Steakhouse.
There's a great
trio playing nearby.
So I was like, OK, cool.
So we went to Roth's.
And I had my horn with me.
And the pianist
playing said, hey,
why don't you come
sit in with the band?
He was great.
The trio was awesome.
And then he said, why
don't you stick around
for the second set?
And we have a
trumpeter coming in.
Is it OK if he sits
in with us too?
I'm like, sure, cool.
It's your gig.
And then who walks in?
The trumpeter is Wynton
Marsalis to Roth's Steakhouse--
in front of like 10 people
who probably didn't even
know who he was because they're
just eating steaks and not
paying attention.
We played a whole
second set together.
And then like a week
later, I got a call
from his people being
like, would Grace
be a guest with Wynton's Jazz
at Lincoln Center Orchestra
at Rose Hall for three nights?
And that was kind of a case
of really going with the flow.
And something way better
and amazing happened.
SPEAKER 1: That's so awesome.
GRACE KELLY: Yeah.
SPEAKER 1: I want to
get back to the music
because there's a lot
more music coming.
GRACE KELLY: Yeah.
SPEAKER 1: But I just--
it's really impressive to
kind of run down your history
because you wrote your
first song at seven.
GRACE KELLY: Yeah.
SPEAKER 1: You recorded
your first record at 12.
GRACE KELLY: Yes.
SPEAKER 1: You wrote an entire
arrangement for the Boston Pops
at 14.
GRACE KELLY: Right.
SPEAKER 1: And you played at
Obama's inauguration at 16.
GRACE KELLY: I'm tired.
Phew.
That's a lot of stuff.
SPEAKER 1: Again.
That's whee-- And it's hard
to read anything about you
without seeing the term prodigy
kind of following you around.
GRACE KELLY: Right.
SPEAKER 1: And I wonder
what your relationship
is to that word.
How do you feel now
that you're a grownup?
You're in the same industry
as many other adults?
Is that something
that you have a mixed
relationship with that word?
Or how has it been to
be a child in jazz?
GRACE KELLY: It's
funny because I never
put that word upon myself.
And it was funny when that word
just started floating around.
I mean I remember the first time
I saw it, it was like, what?
I'm not a prodigy.
It's just something that I found
early on, had amazing teachers,
and was lucky to
find a passion that I
was good at from an early age.
But I guess that's what the
outside world was calling me.
So I never took
it too seriously.
But then I did end up
hearing the word quite a lot.
So I think I have many
feelings with the word.
I'm very glad that
I started young
and was able to
have people start
to know about my music and
all that from a young age.
And then at the same
time, I kind of just
figure I was just practicing,
and doing my thing,
and trying to work really hard
as I continue to do every day.
And that's-- yeah, call
it whatever you want.
SPEAKER 1: And your
musicianship speaks for itself.
So there you go.
GRACE KELLY: Yeah, exactly.
Right.
SPEAKER 1: And let's let
it do that some more.
So Grace Kelly and
the G CAM All Stars.
Give it up for them.
Look at that.
Innovators issue.
Let's have that word.
GRACE KELLY: I met Diego last
time I was here at Google.
I played with them
in the cafeteria.
Now you have this
incredible theater,
which I was saying to Bob is
nicer than a lot of jazz clubs.
It would be-- jazz
musicians would
be so excited if this got in the
roster of the performing tours.
But anyways, this
next song is Diego's.
So do you want to say
anything about it?
SPEAKER 2: Enjoy.
[LAUGHTER]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[CHEERING]
GRACE KELLY: Diego's rumba.
[APPLAUSE]